[Music]
since the beginning of breath of the
wild there have been glitches
most are pretty small simple ones that
people find as they uncover more of the
game but other times you watch as
someone does a multitude of random
things that doesn't make sense that does
something spectacular and you wonder how
did this guy figure this out well it's
almost always a group effort not just a
single person and even in cases where a
glitch was found by one or two people it
was often because of previous
discoveries that were found by even more
people these players share their fines
through discord youtube twitter and
reddit from all over the world in an
international effort one of the most
famous examples of this happening is the
difficult memory storage a complex game
breaking glitch starting a new file with
the all-powerful bow of light and all of
your equipment right off the bat in a
brand new game including the paraglider
which lets you skip the grey plateau
immediately so how did this come to be
how did this extremely complex sequence
get discovered let's break down the long
history of memory storage
let's first quickly explain what it
takes to let you walk around scot-free
with the bow of light to do this glitch
you need to have a cooking pot a travel
medallion a camera a compendium entry a
sheikah sensor plus a side quest and a
memory used together in a very specific
way then load a file and watch a memory
at the same time then die then start a
new game beat it without ever dying then
watch a memory again complete the game
continue an old file which starts a new
game instead then load another file
again
yeah it's a lot this in a very
simplified manner is what it takes to
perform this glitch the next question
would then be how did people figure this
out it absolutely makes no sense when
said in a list like this but there's a
method to the madness let's see how it
started
memory storage was found officially in
december of 2020 almost four years after
the initial release of breath of the
wild making waves throughout the
community but almost no one knows that
its origin was actually found three
months after breath of the wild released
back in june 24th of 2017 a speedrunner
named blue harvey found something
strange while casually playing he wanted
to continue his file in the cryoness
shrine and upon pressing continue
it works
it works the game instead started a
brand new file instead of loading the
previous save how does this work
how
what but not just any new file this file
carried over all this progress from the
previous file such as the doors of the
shriner resurrection already being
opened and this was the beginning of the
new concept of transfers this transfer
known today as flag transfer carries
over your game progress but not your
equipment while inventory transfer
carries over your equipment but not your
progress while this was only flag
transfer it was still a massive find
with huge potential that could lead to a
new game plus file and other glitches in
the future this was only possible
because the glitch blocked autosaves
from occurring but as fast as it came in
version 1.3
it was patched
six days later breath of the wild was in
its heyday with the release of the first
exciting dlc called the master trials
1.3 included the difficult trials for
the fully powered master sword and
various fixes to improve gameplay one of
these fixes was a new return to title
button and some fixes under the hood to
make sure the game would always
guarantee an auto save at the beginning
of the game while it's highly probable
that nintendo didn't even know about
this game-breaking glitch they had
inadvertently smothered this discovery
without ever knowing this glitch was
lost forever with no way to stop auto
saves from occurring right at the
beginning of the game and was slowly
forgotten in time
fast forward three years later on
december 10th 2020 whispers of a weird
glitch started to get uploaded to
twitter by a japanese user named shima
baka catching american player legend of
link's attention while to the average
player this looks like a bunch of menu
nonsense what's actually happening here
is the discovery of being able to hold
different prompts in different
situations outside of where they are
normally supposed to be such as with the
item menu or with champion abilities as
both of these players bounce around
ideas of new ways to hold menu prompts
the conversation moved to discord where
several people joined the discussion and
theory crafting including user kinok who
was experimenting with this as well
without getting too complicated using
things such as the shika sensor the
cooking pot the travel medallion and
pictures they could delay and manipulate
multiple menus at the same time
[Music]
the most interesting prompt though was
the memory prompt as it had more
promising outcomes than the other menus
so they pushed it more and more with the
dlc button with the options menu and
with loading files legend of link and
keynote continued to mess with file
loading but most fines ended with
nothing concrete only soft locks such as
being stuck on this black screen or
staring at a korok forever
but kinak finally noticed that in the
state of watching a memory then loading
a save anything after it will never
auto-save he wanted to take this
technique into the title screen and see
what he could do so he killed himself
then he went to the title screen and
started up a new game but something
strange occurred when he was able to
play again the game still never
auto-saved
this is when legend of link immediately
saw the potential of blue harvey's
legacy three years earlier so on
december 14th 2020 he connected a wii u
trainer to hack the wii u to do more
testing easily and went to work having
experience in this field messing with
file loading glitches before he knew
what he was doing and used hacks to
speed up the process of moving to each
place and only tried to replicate what
you could normally do on a regular
switch
[Music]
since he knew the game couldn't save as
you progressed the next logical thing to
do was to enable saving at the very last
possible time you could which was during
the dark beast ganon fight
after he did so he continued the game
and started up a fresh file but besides
the wall textures not loading nothing in
particular was abnormal until he saw a
curious game finish star on his file he
loaded up that save instead
[Music]
and successfully performed the first
inventory transfer using memory storage
in history transferring all of his items
from his previous file onto a brand new
game unfortunately this didn't have the
bow of light but theorized that having
it equipped in his hands as you beat the
game deletes it from your inventory so
he tried one more time with cheese to
speed up the process and
yes this was big
news spread of having the powerful bow
of light permanently and a new game plus
was discovered players flocked back to
the game spending countless hours
experimenting further and further
pushing the game more after this iconic
glitch only to find that this was just
the beginning of the craziness as this
led to things such as duplicating
colosseum lynels and spirit orbs
getting absolutely absurd amounts of
arrows
which could be chained multiple times to
get all of your arrows to ludicrous
amounts and even getting the ultimate
hylian shield with both max durability
and shield strength
every glitch in every game has its own
story and lineage some based on luck
some based on knowledge and skill but
one thing is for certain as long as
players are looking new and exciting
things will continue to be found if you
enjoyed this video let us know with a
like as we still cover the never ending
game of breath of the wild to this day
and for everything else gaming keep it
here on gamespot
[Music]
you